you may have seen headlines over the
past few days particularly in
conservative outlets claiming that
canada has just banned conversion
therapy which is a political slogan that
refers to counseling that focuses on
changing a person's sexual desires
but the headlines aren't true
canada has not banned all
conversion therapy it is still perfectly
legal in canada to try to change a
person's sexual orientation
so long as you are trying to make that
person homosexual that's very legal it
is legal to try to change a person's
gender identity
so long as you are trying to make that
person
transgender there'll be a lot of quotes
today a lot of air quotes it is
perfectly legal in canada to
this is a real quote from the law
repress or reduce
a person's heterosexual attraction or
behavior as well as to repress or reduce
a person's cisgender
gender identity
all of those conversion therapies
are still legal in canada what is
illegal
is to try to change or repress anyone's
sexual desires or identities
in the other direction in other words if
you try to convince your son that he's
really a little girl that is protected
by the law
but if you tell your little son that he
is not a little girl
you could be sent to prison you could be
imprisoned for five years
many religious liberty advocates point
out that this legislation effectively
outlaws christianity judaism and islam
in canada which is true
but the issue runs far deeper than mere
religious liberty
the legislation outlaws the truth
and it's not just our eccentric
neighbors to the north up in america's
hat who have to worry about that sort of
madness
because a similar law has already been
passed here right in the u.s of a i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from calatheal who
says i haven't been getting
notifications from this channel lately
youtube realizes that you're doing the
right thing and is trying to stop you
thanks so much for speaking the truth
and keep up the good work thank you very
much kalathial we have heard
similar reports from a number of people
that they if they subscribe it'll
they'll be unsubscribed that they're not
getting notifications for our videos
we're seeing this in our analytics
something seems to be afoot
friends at youtube hmm wonder why that
is a reminder that if you want the
uncensored
version of the show that seems to have
the least shenanigans going on in big
tech i head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play get the
audio podcast type in the mic and all
show subscribe leave a five star review
and you should be
okay you know that will help you i think
to sleep at night when you know you're
getting those notifications
and when i want to sleep at night you
know what i do i check out helix you
know about helix i've talked about helix
for years they make these great beds
well now helix is moving beyond just
mattresses
they are starting to make sofas and
they've just launched a new company
called all form they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door so what makes an
all-form sofa really cool well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize a sofa using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric
and it's spill stain scratch resistant
really great fabric you pick the sofa
color the color of the legs the sofa
size the shape you make sure that it is
perfect for you and your home
tailored exactly to your tastes they've
got arm chairs and love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone and you
can always start small and buy more
seats later on all form sofas are also
delivered directly to your door they've
got simple quick assembly no tools
needed if getting a sofa without trying
it in store sounds a little risky you do
not need to worry you get 100 days to
decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund they also have a
forever warranty literally forever and
all form is offering 20 off all orders
for our listeners at allform.com knowles
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
knowles
we already have a similar law in
in america
this law was passed in canada not in
canada in california sorry i get
confused
they're
canada's the avant-garde california is
not so far behind the law in california
stated that
health care workers
who refer to men who think that they are
women as
men and and who do that willfully
can
be prosecuted that that's a crime in
california that law was passed about
five years ago
thankfully it was challenged in the
courts so it's not on the books anymore
but this is what the left wants not just
in other countries but right here in our
own country
they want
they don't want to ban all forms of
sexual social engineering they only want
to ban the forms of sexual social
engineering that go in the traditional
direction
they want to ban the forms of social
engineering sexual social engineering
that tells confused boys that they're
not actually girls but they will
encourage
all the other forms of social sexual
they'll encourage all the other forms of
conversion therapy as long as it goes in
the direction of radicalism and very
often fantasy
the law in canada
just like the law in california when it
was passed
it's not a valid law
it's not i know it's on the books i know
it's going to be enforced i know that
the political system in canada is going
to do everything it can to to make this
the law of land but it's not a valid law
the reason for that is that human law is
only
law by virtue of its accordance with
right reason
it it
is manifest that it flows from the
eternal law insofar as it deviates from
right reason it is called an unjust law
and in such a case it is no law at all
but rather a species of violence that's
the description
by saint thomas aquinas one of the most
intelligent people ever to live and it
has been repeated by people throughout
the ages martin luther king actually
said similar things it was martin luther
king day just a couple of days ago
unjust law is no law at all because
human law is only law
in in its accordance with right reason
and so when you have an unjust law that
is not a law that is a species of
violence what they're doing in canada is
committing violence on parents on kids
especially and it it must not be
followed evil evil
stuff we got into this problem
not just because the left led us there
but because the right let us there as
well this is being talked about as a
religious liberty issue
it is a religious liberty issue but
that's not the primary problem
it's a truth issue
it's a truth issue we got into this
problem because we deny the truth the
left obviously denies the truth they say
that falsehood is truth and truth is
falsehood but the conservatives do it as
well or at least the libertarians do in
the conservative movement because very
often you will hear people on the right
say well how do we know
how do we know how do we legislate
morality who's to say who decides
maybe the thing you think is good i
think is bad shouldn't we all be allowed
to just make up our own understanding of
what's good and bad man you know hold on
let me just
yeah you know man and it's like what if
the color you see as green i see is blue
and it's this radical skepticism
that sounds no different
than what anthony kennedy wrote in the
supreme court decision planned
parenthood v casey where he
found somewhere in the constitution i
guess an invisible inc a right to define
your own concept of existence
those are the the ramblings of some aged
hippie but they're often repeated by
right wingers and so when we deny the
truth when we deny that we can know the
truth with some reasonable degree of
certainty then we open ourselves up to
this kind of
madness
the problem here is not just that the
left has completely lost its mind and is
peddling insanity and child abuse
the other problem is that the right is
not willing to stand up for the truth
and doesn't have the confidence to
articulate the truth
if you oppose
transiting all the kids like they're
trying to do in canada
you will today be called a far right
extremist
everyone to the right of hillary clinton
today as a far right extremist even some
people who are to the left of hillary
clinton
but but oppose the dominant ruling class
the liberal establishment they will also
be called far right extremists a great
example of this is glenn greenwald glenn
greenwald
has been for most of his career a
leftist a left-wing
activist and journalist
glenn greenwald
has had contact with wikileaks with
edward snowden
i think he's a gay guy i'm not sure
he
worked in some weird
sexual
industry type jobs earlier in his career
according to reports he's not what you
would call a traditional rock-ribbed
conservative
i i suspect most of his views are not
particularly conservative
but glenn greenwald
opposes the liberal establishment glenn
greenwald is willing to do the job of a
journalist at least some of the time
and so as a result the ruling class has
labeled him a far right
right wing no longer means
what it used to mean these these phrases
these terms change over time the left
and the right the the very words left
and right in our political discourse
come from the french revolution when the
right wingers supported the monarchy and
the left wingers wanted to plunge the
country into madness and the left winger
is obviously one but today we don't
necessarily think of right wingers as
monarchists so the the words change
quite a lot over time and now far right
means you oppose the ruling class so
we're all far right now guys
okay we're all
it just means bad
it's just it's what the liberals did to
the word racist racist no longer means
that you have animosity for people on
the basis of their race racist just
means bad
so if you're a bad person if i don't
like you so if if you're someone that
the dominant power structure doesn't
like you're a racist
or you're far right or you're a
white nationalist or whatever
this is the the politics of politics
this is the overton window is sometimes
what it's called the the left by
manipulating all the terms which i write
about my book speechless controlling
words controlling minds by by changing
the the limits of acceptable discourse
every society is gonna have some
discourse that's off limits doesn't
matter how much you love your first
amendment certain things you're just not
allowed to say in every society if they
can shift that all the way over to the
left then even leftists are going to
appear to be far right wing there's
another part of the politics of politics
though beyond the issues beyond
immigration and pro-life and the economy
there's the
the politics about how we do politics
and you see some of that in the
discourse and you see some of that in
how the elections
are
run
and we got some really good news on this
out of wisconsin out of waukesha
wisconsin
a judge in waukesha
just came out
and said that
election drop boxes are not
permissible so election drop boxes are
one of the tools that the left used in
2020 to change all the election rules to
push their guy joe biden through joe
biden the most popular president ever
even though those approval ratings are
are in the 30s
he got more votes than anybody how dare
you if you question that you're an
insurrectionist far-right terrorist
they changed all the rules one of them
was you have these very insecure ballot
drop boxes the judge in waukesha says
absolutely
not we're not going to do that so
great news for republicans looking at
2022 and 2024. great news for you and
your family looking at your next dinner
good ranchers you know how much i hate
being lied to and we have been lied to a
lot especially in the past couple of
years
well you're being lied to every time you
go to the grocery store it turns out
that 85 of the grass-fed beef in the
united states is imported from overseas
but it's often labeled product of usa
how do they get away with it because
they do minimal processing while they're
here and so they say yeah basically it's
a product of the usa don't buy that
cheap imported beef that lacks true
flavor go to goodranchers.com knowles to
cut through the misinformation get 100
american beef delivered to your door
today good ranchers only sells beef that
is born raised and harvested in the usa
they're 100 american in steakhouse
quality plus you can save 30 bucks right
now with my code knowles canadawlis at
checkout that's 30 bucks off any box
that is the biggest discount they have
ever offered
today is the day to do it save big on
your new favorite steak they're the
exclusive meat company of the daily wire
for good reason head on over to
goodranchers.com knowles to save 30
bucks i just had their strip steaks the
other day it was absolutely magnificent
then i actually had their burgers two
days later just phenomenal make 2022
your most flavorful year yet good
ranchers american meat delivered
conservatives are not going to win
elections if we do not
make sure that the elections are fair
a lot of republicans don't think the
2020 election
was fair
an even higher percentage of democrats
don't think the 2016 election was fair
now their claims are not equal
because in 2016 the election was run
like it always is and the reason
democrats don't think it was fair is
because our intelligence agencies made
up a bunch of crap about trump colluding
with the russians which wasn't true the
reason that people don't think the 2020
election was fair was because democrats
changed all the rules and in some cases
violated state constitutions when they
cheated to get their guy across the
finish line so they're not i'm not
saying it's all all equal here however
it is a political problem that both
sides don't think that the elections are
fair so what are we going to do we need
to make sure that the elections are fair
are just are equitable
and are not being stolen by the
democrats or are advantageous to
republicans and to the rule of law and
to justice
because right now they're skewed so much
in the direction of the democrats we've
got to do that
i don't care how popular your view on
immigration is i don't care how well
you're doing in the polls and how
terribly your opponent is doing in the
polls if if you don't have
some semblance of a fair election then
that and buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee you've got to make sure so the
first battle for republicans is make
sure that the drop boxes the no id
voting the election month election
season all of these ridiculous cheats
that the democrats have instituted that
you got to make sure that those go away
then you've got to work on the cultural
front on moving the overton window which
political actors can play a large role
in then you work on the policies but
you're not going to get to that third
part unless you take care of the first
part speaking of con confusing the left
and the right
the the left is still
pushing the russia hoax the russia hoax
has been so
completely discredited
we know that
it was based on a an unverified
false dossier that was paid for by
hillary clinton that was used as an
excuse to spy on the trump campaign and
then later to undermine the trump
presidency with the overt collusion of
not just our intelligence agencies but
international intelligence as well it
was based on nothing the best they could
find was that russia spent a hundred
grand on facebook ads in in the 2016
campaign that was pretty much the best
evidence available to them
okay and they're still pushing it
they're still saying that republicans
are shilling for russia take a listen to
msnbc
so they're asking uh
joe biden to unilaterally disarm i'm
gonna i'm gonna defend the rhetoric that
the language that the president used in
georgia uh with you chuck i think that
right now our democracy is imperial john
tester who is not somebody who's given
to hyperbole a moderate to montana said
this is the most important thing that
he's going to face while he's in that
senate so i think that uh both bansham
and cinema need to recognize that
telling democrats right now to disarm is
like telling ukrainians to disarm with
putin at the border if mitch mcconnell
were
had the 50-50 senate right now the
ability to break a tie he would applaud
the filibuster a long time ago here we
go so you still hear this russia
analogy
this guy the head of the center for
american progress he's not saying trump
colluded with russia he's not saying
that
the
republicans are are selling out america
to russia but he is making a comparison
and in the comparison the republicans
are the russians which is a little
awkward right now because right now the
biden administration is helping to
facilitate the russian takeover of
ukraine
it's actually the republicans who are
opposing it
very few people know this because no one
really cares that much about foreign
policy but that's what's going on right
now democrats are supporting putin in
his ambitions specifically because
vladimir putin is trying to complete an
oil pipeline that will allow them to cut
out ukraine it's called nordstrom 2.
once the
putin competes completes that pipeline
which ted cruz and the republicans are
opposing in which the democrats and
biden and the state department are
supporting then putin has no reason not
to go in and expand his influence into
ukraine so the comparison here is pretty
pretty weak
but it's even more complicated it's even
more complicated than all of that
because when you think of republicans
colluding with the russians
and that's bad putin bad and
republican's bad and they're taking over
a sovereign nation ukraine it gets even
weirder because
ukraine has been an independent nation
for a very short period of time in world
history ukraine has been conquered by
basically everybody
it was conquered by the
austro-hungarian empire it was conquered
by the ottoman empire it was conquered
by zarist russia the russian empire it
was conquered by the soviet empire it
was conquered by poland poland is one of
the most conquered countries in the
history of the world and
and ukraine managed to get conquered by
poland ukraine almost certainly derives
from the slavic word for borderland it
means borderland it's always going to be
this area of conflict
the russians are looking at at it as a
border to protect them against nato and
the west the west is looking at ukraine
as a border for europe against russia's
ambitions and so they're going to fight
over it that's what's going on
and and we still have to believe that
putin is the greatest enemy of america
and that it's still 1986.
putin wants to expand his influence of
course he does there's no question about
it but is vladimir putin really our our
greatest threat i don't think so i think
we face a far greater threat from china
right now china which has a lot more
money a lot more people owns a lot more
of america owns our debt owns a lot of
resources here
so okay you you've got an enemy in putin
you've got an enemy in china
don't you think it might make a little
bit of sense and hear me out on this
to try to collude with the russians i
don't i
when when democrats accuse republicans
of colluding with the russians
i get i get very sad because i think no
i think we should collude with the
russians but we're actually not
colluding with the russians right now
because i think it would be very wise as
we're trying to stave off a rising china
to maybe do what we did in the cold war
in reverse during the cold war we were
trying to stop the soviet union so what
did we do we warmed up relations with
china
we got a little cozier with them and we
tried to play the chinese off the
russians well why don't we do the same
thing here now that russia's not the
threat in china is a much bigger threat
why don't we cozy up to the russians and
play the russians off with the chinese
what the liberal establishment has done
is is alienate both of those guys and
push russia and china closer together
than ever both the russians and the
chinese are saying their relationship is
extremely extremely tight right now
tighter than it's ever been before what
there there are still wedges there are
wedges on trade their wedges on
resources you actually could play them
off one another
but not if we keep using this dumb
rhetoric that the establishment in our
country has been using for decade upon
decade and decade far
after its usefulness furthermore
furthermore when we're talking about
expanding american influence what are we
even talking about if expanding american
influence
throughout the world throughout ukraine
and even encroaching on other people's
territories
if that means spreading truth justice in
the american way the traditional
american way of life well that's one
thing
but if expanding american influ
influence means raising pride flags in
kandahar and transiting the kids frankly
i don't want to spread that influence i
think it would be bad to spread that
kind of influence around the world
and i don't blame other nations for for
wanting to resist that influence so what
is it
what is it what is it that we're
actually spreading
because right now
what russia is doubling down on is
national cohesion
nationalism it's doubling down on
christianity vladimir putin is funding
beautiful a beautiful cathedral the
military cathedral that is one of the
most gorgeous buildings built in the
last century
he might not he might not believe a
single word of christianity
but as a political matter that's what
the country is focusing on
russia which is a very expansive
multi-ethnic country is focusing on that
and it seems to be working pretty well
russia which is facing a a problem of
the country literally dying just like
america the birth rates are below
replacement well russia actually
implemented some policies to turn that
around only two countries in the west
have done that russia and hungary i'm
not saying we copy what they're doing
necessarily but maybe we could learn
some lessons from that
and maybe as we're looking at the
threats to american influence abroad
maybe we get a little bit smarter about
it and recognize where the threats
really lie
which is not in
that
frozen country up in eurasia that we
beat in the cold war but a little
further south in china
the only thing more complicated than
foreign policy and trying to make sense
of what we are usually presented with as
these extremely oversimplified
caricatures of of foreign policy issues
the only thing more complicated
is is trying to make sense of the new
york times there was a new york times
article just came out
about the crime surge that we're dealing
with right now all throughout american
cities crime is going through the roof
and then here they just can't understand
why it doesn't make you know they
the left last year defunded the police
tried to abolish the police in some
cases let criminals off the hook for
their crimes let a lot of criminals out
of jail and said that they wouldn't
enforce the law and now crime is going
up it's a real head scratcher i can't hm
what what maybe it's something about the
virus i don't know maybe it's maybe
that's a symptom of covid as people get
more violent so the new york times can't
make sense of this
the closest they get is they say quote
the fallout from the 2020 racial justice
protests and riots
could have contributed to the murder
spike
police officers scared of being caught
in the next viral video
may have pulled back
on proactive
anti-violence practices
is anyone out there maybe if you're
writing in the comments could could
anyone translate that into english for
me
they the police
may have
pulled back
on proactive
anti-violence
policies
is
i guess every word there is english but
when you put it all together that
doesn't seem to make a coherent
sentence it's just a bunch of
pretentious jargon and mealy-mouthed
language trying to
avoid something
i guess oh they're trying to avoid the
obvious which is if you want crime to go
down i'll simplify this as best i can
want crime down
arrest criminals
crime go down
criminals go prison is that is that
simple enough for the new york times i
don't know if they can get it through
their heads
then today is going to be talking about
how just one year in
with the crime
with the terrible economy with the
lockdowns with the threats to our rights
just one year and joe biden is already
the worst president ever he's been
talking about that on the show today
don't miss it i'm michael knowles we
will be right back
the new york times can't figure out why
crime is going up after we defunded the
police and let all the criminals off the
hook so they've got their they're on to
something though they've got a lead
here's their lead they say
these three factors could have played
into each other
the pandemic might have driven more
people to violence you know the pandemic
you know that virus when someone says oh
my body's aching
i got this cough
i really want to just rob a nike store
oh yeah i just
oh gosh with all
these aches and pains and i lost my
sense of smell and taste
let me go
stick up a family on the street yeah
that
i just i don't know i'm just i feel
impelled to do that so they say it's the
pandemic could have done it the police
might have been able to prevent at least
some of the violence if they had
remained proactive or had worked better
with the public
so if the police had just done their
jobs
like we wouldn't let them do
then we probably wouldn't be in this
mess right now
well you got you're the ones new york
times and liberals you're the ones who
said the police shouldn't do their jobs
but now you're blaming them for not
doing their jobs you wouldn't let them
do their jobs well they have an answer
you see that that's in the last part of
the sentence they say or if they'd
worked better with the public so if the
police
hadn't
forced us
to force them to stop doing their jobs
then they could have done their jobs at
all be better it's their fault
police if you just hadn't made me so
angry if you hadn't made me so angry
then we wouldn't be in this position
seems a little a little unfair seems
i don't think that reason
and argument quite works and then
finally they say without so many guns
what violence did occur could have ended
up less deadly that's the gun's fault
it's the guns it's the virus's fault
it's the cops fault it's the inanimate
object's fault
what's the only group that the new york
times is not blaming for the surge in
crime
it's um
hold on
oh the criminals
it's the criminal it's not the criminals
bear no responsibility and the leftist
politicians who let all the criminals
off the hook and out of jail they bear
no responsibility
it's
the cops
and the inanimate objects
and a coronavirus
from china
i don't know listen i'm not
i'm not one of these geniuses who works
at the very fancy new york times i
do not have advanced degrees in
criminology
or anything like that
but it seems simple enough to me the new
york times actually has gotten into this
trouble before it was fox butterfield
their reporter who would have headlines
decades ago we'd have headlines in the
new york times that would say things
like
the crime rate
the crime rate continues to fall
despite prisons filling despite
as though as though this would be
unexpected that when you throw criminals
in jail the crime rate goes down as
though maybe
there's no way that these things could
have anything to do with one another
speaking of crime there is a democrat
candidate running for senate right now
who is
smoking a fat blunt in his campaign ad
and running on the platform of letting
other people puff on the devil's lettuce
every 37 seconds someone is arrested for
possession of marijuana since 2010 state
and local police have arrested an
estimated 7.3 million americans for
violating marijuana laws over half of
all drug arrests black people are four
times more likely to be arrested for
marijuana laws than white people states
waste 3.7 billion dollars enforcing
marijuana laws every year most of the
people police are arresting aren't
dealers but rather people with small
amounts of pot just like me i'm gary
chambers and i'm running for the u.s
senate and i approve this message
i
so hope
that that guy
got arrested
i assume he didn't but i just i have
this dream that that guy is sitting
there
spreading complete lies about
drugs and the criminal justice system
just complete made up nonsense he's
sitting there smoking his blunt and he's
filming and he's saying yeah you got to
vote for me because the most important
issue in america the reason i'm running
for senate is so that people can just
smoke up that peruvian parsley every day
that'll make america great
and then they finish they say cut okay
we we're good we're good senate
candidate guy and then you just you're
like
and then the guy goes into the clink
this
guy
is not telling the truth about drug laws
in america we are told by the pothead
contingent now it's not even just the
pod head contingent that i i have any
problems with and it's not even
marijuana that i specifically have a
problem with
it's the it's the people
who
insist on the legalization of marijuana
as a cure is something that'll make
america so great and it'll it'll improve
society it's those people the obsessive
pro-legalization people they are the
reason
that i want to ban
every joint from america because they
are so annoying and dumb and wrong
that i don't want to hear them anymore
and that's one of the reasons i want to
do it
what this man is saying is not true
we're told that
the prisons are just full of poor men
usually black men by the way who were
arrested for simple possession they had
a joint they were just smoking a little
bit now they're going to jail for years
they're being probably 90 percent of the
prison population it's just these poor
men
who were just trying to
just trying to puff on a little little
sin spinach and and they got arrested
that's not true
according to the hudson institute which
did a great review of this
just 3.6
of state prison inmates are in
jail for possession offenses of any kind
we're not we're not talking about
marijuana here we're talking about
heroin we're talking about fentanyl
we're talking about really bad stuff
that kills a lot of people
for possession of any kind it's just 3.6
when you when you go up to the federal
prisons
the number is even lower it's 0.9
percent
so why this confusion
well
it's actually not even just the 3.6 and
the 0.9 percent the numbers are actually
even lower because drug traffickers
usually plea down their their cases so
someone who's in prison for possession
very often is in prison for drug
trafficking and they just plead it down
and so then you you see them there for
simple possession in 2014 which is the
most recent year for which the hudson
institute has compiled its data the
number of inmates sentenced to federal
prison for marijuana possession
take a guess
if that pothead senate candidate is to
be believed you'd think what
50 000 people
10 000 people
certainly at least you'd say seven or
eight thousand people right
because the prisons are just filled with
this probably you'd think even even more
no the number
was 75
people not 75 000
not 7 500 75 people in 2014 were
sentenced to federal prison for
marijuana possession 97 of federal
inmates who are in for drugs are in for
drug trafficking
add to that that last year 100 000
americans died from drug overdoses
leading cause of death for young
americans
that was up 30 percent over the previous
year and these idiots
think that the the way to deal with that
are amer or fellow americans poisoning
themselves to death
the way to deal with that
historic surge in drug overdoses is to
legalize drugs because of a problem that
doesn't exist namely the problem of mass
incarceration for simple possession
which is just a fantasy lock that away
with the tooth fairy and the easter
bunny
i don't know i don't know how that
senate candidate could have come up with
such stupid fantastical
ideas that are so divorced from reality
oh yeah i know because he's super high
that's probably that's probably why he
came up with it
good grief
if the if the smoke clouds would clear
away not not from the air in front of
him but from his brain he could look at
the real numbers and realize
that that what he's selling is a really
bad idea and it's unfortunate because so
many conservatives who are in under the
sway of the libertines on the right the
you know maybe the libertarians even who
say well it's not the government's right
to stop you from doing drugs
they think this is fine too
if you believe
that giving that dude his way
that pothead senate candidate who thinks
that puffing a drug is the most
important issue in american politics if
you think that doing what he wants is
going to make america better
i got a bridge in brooklyn to sell you
speaking of our justice system
all the way up to the supreme court some
of the justices are not happy with one
another one in particular
sonia sotomayor who refuses
to appear
in
the chambers with the other judges in
person
because justice neil gorsuch refuses to
wear a mask
we are now in the um
second year
we're now entering into the third year
of the two weeks to slow the spread for
a virus that doesn't pose a great threat
to most people
we're now in the surge of omicron which
is equivalent
in its symptoms usually to a cold
i just had it i just recovered from it
wasn't nice but it's fine
and sonia sotomayor says no she is not
going to appear if justice gorsuch won't
wear a mask
now some people are saying this is a
problem seems to me this is a solution
to the problem
if
if i can get rid of all of the sonia
sotomayors
simply by breathing
and not putting a secular kefia over my
face
i think we're good i think we figured it
out good stuff great job thanks for
sticking firm on this issue neil gorsuch
the question that it raises is should
gorsuch wear masks to be nice to sonia
sotomayor should all of us should we
wear masks
indefinitely
to be nice
to the people who are neurotic about the
virus
no
that's that's not nice generally
speaking there might be some exception
if your aged grandma is really insistent
that you wear a mask around her then out
of filial piety maybe you do it but
generally speaking no we should not
indulge this stuff it is
it is not merely because the virus is
not as dangerous as the experts told us
it was it is not merely because we're
two years into two weeks to slow the
spread it's because it is bad for
society for us all to mask ourselves up
it's bad for human development
it's bad bad for kids it's bad for
babies it's bad for all of us though we
we should be able to see one another
smile we should be able to breathe the
fresh air we should be able to read the
emotions on other people's faces
we should
not be living in terror of a little tiny
virus
and cowering in our homes looking on our
fellow men whom we should love as our
brothers as walking bags of disease who
are out to kill us
it is disordered for a society to mask
itself up
and it's bad for these individuals like
sonia sotomayor and others
who are allowing
neurosis to [ __ ] them
we should not encourage that that's very
wrong rachel maddow my doppelganger over
on msnbc has a different take she wants
to know how neil gorsuch can live with
himself
she writes quote it's folly to try to
get inside anyone else's head i know but
i just can't shake this
does justice gorsuch revel in everyone
now knowing that he's keeping her
sonia sotomayor from being able to come
to work or is he embarrassed i mean how
do you live with yourself
i will tell you
doppelganger i will tell you ms meadow
because i do this too i refuse in any
circumstance that i possibly can i guess
with the exception of going on airplanes
i i don't wear the mask and haven't for
the entirety of of the lockdowns
the way that we live with ourselves
is like normal people we just live
normally and not abnormally and we live
like people who are in command of their
reason and not like people who are under
a mass delusion and psychosis that's how
we live
how do you how can you walk out the door
without covering your your face in a
cloth mask that now even the public
health experts tell us don't work how do
how can you do uh well we did it for um
all of human history until two years ago
and so that's how we do that but you
might get someone sick how do you
walk around in a world teeming with
germs
and not have that [ __ ] you into
staying in your closet for two years uh
well because that's how human society
has always existed
and we that's how we have to live
because there are germs in the world and
you're not going to get rid of the germs
and you you might you might get covet
and you you might get the flu and you
might catch a cold
and you you might get you might get mono
hey if you're in school i don't know
sharing a coca-cola with a friend you
might get mono you might get
you might get all sorts of things and
you'll almost certainly be fine but you
know what you might get really sick
you could go get a really bad flu and
you could die
you might die
from the germs that you're encountering
in the world
that's life that's the cost of living
that if you don't
if you don't want to do that then
you're not going to get along very well
and how do you live rachel how do you
live how do you live with yourself i
hope that you're not trapping yourself
in a closet cowering in fear of the
little virus the question for all of us
is how do we want to live
what we have done is outsource that
question for two years to some egghead
twerp named dr fauci who is going to
tell us exactly how we should live
based on absolutely no expertise he's
not particularly philosophically or
theologically
sophisticated
he is not supposed to be holding a
position of making these kind of broad
sweeping policies
he's supposed to be an infectious
disease expert but we've given him the
authority to make all of these decisions
that he's not qualified to make and
really has no right to make how do we
want to live i want to live in a world
where we don't
dress up like mummies all the time and
live in fear of one another how do you
want to live
a great
a great example
of this question for society that we
have to ask ourselves how do we want to
live not just how do i want to live
do i do i want to chop my body up so i
look like a different sex and smoke pot
all the time and dress up not just how i
want to live but how do we want to live
in a society because no man is an
individual atom floating in free space
a great example of this just happened on
american
airlines olivia culpo
who was miss universe
she is one of the most beautiful women
on planet earth olivia culpo showed up
to a flight
to cabo san lucas
wearing a very skimpy outfit she was
wearing a little looked like just a bra
and some extremely tight kind of
leggings and she i think she had a
sweater but it was open and she shows up
and
she looked hotter than a two dollar
pistol there's no question about it and
the stewardess on the flight said you
gotta cover up ladies you gotta put a
shirt on or we're not gonna allow you on
the flight and she threw a big hissy fit
or her sister or someone in her family
through a big hissy fit about it
i can't believe i can't believe i'm
saying this 12 year old michael would be
very upset with 31 year old michael for
saying this
american airlines was right
olivia culpo should
should cover up
people have the right not to be
constantly titillated
every man listening to this show
almo almost every man listening to this
show
has a part of them that would really
like to see olivia culpo wear
extremely tight scandalous clothing to
the to the airport on their there's a
part of man that wants to see that
but
at least the men who are not just
complete degenerates have another part
to them that that don't want to see that
because
we want to read our book or we want to
do our work or we want to have a
conversation and we don't want to be
completely distracted by this bombshell
who's sitting next to us on an airplane
wearing her underwear
you don't because you want to do other
things in your life
but we have forgotten that
because we now live in a culture where
where women actually just wear leggings
as though their pants and wear bras is
they're their shirts and so we're
constantly titillated all the time and
it is
it is not conducive to a flourishing
society i remember thinking this when i
would take exams sometimes and girls
would show up wearing this kind of
clothing i think this is unfair
because i'm going to do worse on the
exam now because i'm distracted by this
hot girl wearing very little clothing
and she's never going to be distracted
by me
it's not as though i could walk into an
exam wearing my birthday suit and all
the girls would say oh my gosh wow i
can't no they'd probably just ignore it
this is not conducive to a good society
this is why we have laws against
indecent exposure
right this is why i'm actually not
allowed to walk around in my birthday
suit and people are
generally happy about that i don't know
maybe some people
maybe it titillates them too but we live
in a society
and so the individual right to wear your
underwear in public
it must be
suppressed
for the broader collective right the
community right
the political right
to not constantly be
titillated
that this is something that
the libertarian version of the right
wing in america doesn't
doesn't really get or doesn't really go
along with but the conservative version
of the conservative movement in america
obviously gets
if a woman if a woman dressed like this
in the days of our founding fathers she
would probably be run out of town on the
rail she would should probably be called
a witch
she'd be right away she they wouldn't
what i'm saying i'm not saying olivia
culpo's a witch he seems like a lovely
lady but
this would not be tolerated
even those great defenders of freedom
the founding fathers the great men who
built our country that's not what
freedom is
freedom to be distracted all the time
is no freedom at all
the reason this stuff should be
encouraged is not because men don't like
them but because men do like them and we
live in a society and we like them a
little too much and we can't have that
speaking of younger people
belgium
belgium is committing a grave act of
covid misinformation they are because
belgium and the health ministry in
belgium is no longer recommending that
young people take the moderna vaccine
people under the age of 31 so we're not
even just talking about 12 year olds
we're talking about under the age of 31
belgium says no
don't take the moderna vaccine because
there is a risk of heart inflammation
myocarditis
this this was announced by the belgian
vaccination
task force
this is very confusing because we were
told that there were no safety concerns
with the vaccines and actually
we
communicators broadcasters were told
that if we ever say that there are any
safety concerns with these vaccines
we are liable to be banned from youtube
or twitter or facebook receive a strike
be shut down
my show has been censored many times for
saying very basic things like what the
belgian health ministry is saying now
according to the brussels times danish
studies indicate quote that vaccination
with modernity resulted in an increased
risk of heart inflammation in young men
following the first or first or second
dose in comparison with the pfizer
so first we were told
there were no there are no safety
concerns
by all the experts it's completely safe
then we were told there are safety
concerns but you should get it anyway
because
the the risk
from the vaccines is less than the risk
of having heart inflammation say from
covid now we're being told by the public
health officials no actually just don't
get this vaccine this is bad
it would be better for you not to get
this vaccine
do the public health officials realize
why we don't believe them
they have told us things that are not
true and they've said they're 100
certain about them
in some cases they've told us things
that they know are not true by their own
admission like dr fauci on the masks or
the public health officials on the lab
league theory
from the wuhan institute of virology
they'll tell us things that they that
they themselves don't believe are true
but they think that we should know them
and now now they tell us things with 100
certainty they say believe us now
it would be madness it would be absolute
madness to believe them
now
very short story before we go there's a
headline from the ap that kamala harris
is struggling to to define herself
that they're based on this reporting
that they've found talking to people
around
kamala harris she's very frustrated
because she's trying to reset her public
image multiple times now it hasn't
worked she she can't define herself
the reason she can't define herself is
because she doesn't stand for anything
my advice to kamala harris is that she
should believe in something ideally the
truth but anything at all would be a
good start she's tough on crime she's
weak on crime she's a far leftist she's
a moderate she's a racial grievance
person she's a come together kumbaya
person she's just she just
licks her finger puts it in the air
tries to figure out which way the wind
is blowing don't be a kamala politician
it's pointless she will be completely
forgotten at this rate no no one
generally remembers vice presidents in
american history and she is one of the
worst ones ever so i guess she could be
remembered in that sort of infamy she
will have accomplished nothing she's
never accomplished anything in her
political career other than
winning elections or more usually i
guess being being selected and appointed
don't be a kamala politician it's weak
there's you don't gain anything from it
stand for something ideally the truth
which is now illegal
in the western world up to our neighbors
to the north and increasingly in america
as well i'm michael knowles as the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
is one year into his presidency and it
is a gigantic failure on every single
level can you pull out of the tailspin
that's today on the bench bureau should
i give it a listen